وافاد مراسل الجزيره بان طائرات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي قصفت مباني عده في منطقه بني
سهيله شرقيه خانيونس وحصلت الجزيره على
صور تظهر تصاعد اعمده الدخان في مناطق
مختلفه من خانيونس التي تشهد منذ الصباح
اشتباكات بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه معنا من رفح مراسل الجزيره
هشام زقوت هشام لعلك اطلعت اكثر خلال
الساعه الاخيره عن جديد القصف الذي يستهدف
خان يونس ورفح وعن هذه الاشتباكات
المستمره ايضا
هناك بالفعل هي اشتباكات مستمره ويسمع
المواطنون اشتباكات
وانفجارات في مناطق مختلفه في قطاع غزه لا
سما في خانيونس في جنوب القطاع وكذلك في
مناطق شمال القطاع في جباليا والمناطق
الشرقيه لجبال في بيت حنون وكذلك في بيت
لاهيه هذه الاشتباكات مستمره وعلى ما يبدو
انها ناجمه عن تقدم الدبابات الاسرائيليه
في اكثر من محور من تلك المناطق لكنه ليس
تقدما ملحوظا او كبيرا كما كان يحدث في
السابق لكن هي تقدمات للجيش الاسرائيلي
وحتى ان كانت تقدمات بسيطه
فالمقاومة تقدمات وهذه الاشتباكات فالقصف
الاسرائيلي مستمر ومتواصل على اكثر من
منطقه وبات يتركز حتى في شمال القطاع التي
هدا القصف عنها قبل عده ايام لكن منذ عده
ايام ونحن نرصد القصف الاسرائيلي على شمال
القطاع قصف مدفعي قصف من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه ما بين فينه واخرى هناك قصف
من الطائرات يستهدف في جله منازل مدنيه
فلسطينيه في جباليا وكذلك في احياء مختلفه
من قطا من مدينه غزه في حي تل الهواء
شهدنا منزلا وايضا في حي الصبره وكذلك في
حي الزيتون وكذلك في حي الدرج وكل هذه
المنازل كنا نرصد القصف الاسرائيلي عليها
وكان هناك عشرات من الشهداء والجرحى لان
هذه المنازل مكتظه بسبب عدم وجود منازل
اصلا في مدينه غزه وفي شمال القطاع فاحيا
بكاملها دمرت من قبل الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه على مدار هذه الحرب ايضا
القصف مستمر على المنطقه الوسطى لا سياما
مخيم النصيرات ومخيم البريج ومخيم المغازي
هذه المخيمات ما زالت تتعرض الى قصف عنيف
من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه وكذلك ما بين
فينه واخرى هناك غارات اسرائيليه تنفذها
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه التي تحلق
بكثافه في سماء انحاء مختلفه من القطاع
تدمر هذه الغارات في الغالب منازل مدنيه
فلسطينيه في تلك المناطق بعدما دمرت احياء
بكاملها ومربعات سكنيه بكاملها في هذه
المخيمات البسيطه والتي تحتوي على منازل
ايضا بسيطه ومتلاصقة
ناطق يدمر مربعات سكنيه من جراء غاره
واحده على منزل واحد مستهدف القصف
الاسرائيلي ايضا كان مكثفا على شمال مخيم
النصيرات لا سما منطقه المغرا مدينه
الزهراء ايضا المخيم الجديد ارض المفتي
مازالت تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه المناطق الشرقيه لدير البلح
كذلك هي الاخرى تتعرض الى قصف مدفعي عنيف
من الاليات والدبابات الاسرائيليه
المتمركزه على الحدود الشرقيه لقطاع غزه
لكن ربما القصف الاكثر عنفا والاكثر كثافه
والاكثر حده هو في خانيونس جنوب قطاع غزه
حيث احياء قيزان النجار وجوره اللوت
والبطن السمين ومحيط مستشفى ناصر الذي بات
يتعرض منذ امس الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه وهناك غارات ما بين فينه
واخرى ايضا تشنها الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه على تلك المناطق ما زال القصف
يسمع صداه في اقصى مدينه رفح حيث نتواجد
نسمع ما بين الفينه والاخرى قصف من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه على تلك المناطق
ويصل صداها الى هنا القصف على رفح كان
مركزا وخلال الايام الماضيه نحن نرصد
القصف على رفح القصف على رفح يستهدف في
جله مهازل مدنيه فلسطينيه تدمرها الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه على رؤوس السكان
الذين يتواجدون فيها وهؤلاء السكان هم من
سكان مدينه رفح وايضا نازحون اتوا الى رفح
بعدما طلب الجيش الاسرائيلي من السكان ان
توجهوا الى رفح توجه ججه الى مخيم
الشابوره والى يبنه والى حي الجنينه والى
حي السلطان وبالتالي القصف الاسرائيلي في
رفح بات مركزا على منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه
ويوقع عشرات الشهداء والجرحى بسبب
الاكتظاظ السكاني في مدينه رفح التي كان
يقطنها 300000 نسمه واليوم مليون او اكثر
من مليون و300 ال نسمه بالتالي القصف
الاسرائيلي على رفح استهدف منزلا في
المناطق الشرقيه لرفح واستشهد اكثر من 19
فلسطينيا ثمانيه من افال وهناك نساء بكل
تاكيد وهناك عشرات من المفقودين في رفح
ظلوا تحت الانقاض ما تزال طواقم الدفاع
المدني وطواقم الاسعاف تحاول جاهده
لاخراجه هشام زقوت من رفح شكرا جزيلا
لك